i pranking tonight just moments ago the
Washington Post reported Robert Muller
has informed president Trump's lawyers
at the president well still the
witch-hunt continues however he is not
currently a criminal target there's
important news the post is also
reporting Muller is quote preparing to a
report about the president's actions
while in office and potential
obstruction of justice and we're going
to analyze this new development in a
minute but first we also have the
president refusing to back away from his
promise to secure America's borders now
here's the current situation Congress
has repeatedly failed to pass tough
immigration laws and people are flooding
into our country Democrats they have
been obstructing every single step of
the way they're not interested in
solving problems they're not even
interested in helping daca recipients
because they want to make this a big
campaign issue in 2018 this year and
according to reports that caravan of
more than a thousand asylum seekers and
immigrants heading for the United States
has now reportedly stalled out in Mexico
this comes after the president said he
pressured Mexico to do so watch this I
have just heard that the caravan coming
up from Honduras is broken up and Mexico
did that and they did it because frankly
I said you really have to do it we're
gonna have a relationship with NAFTA
we're gonna have to include security and
NAFTA so Mexican very strong laws and
that's the way it is so it looks like
it's been broken up now the president
also tonight signaling that he has done
playing games when it comes to our
border security he is now saying he will
use the US military to help secure the
border let's take a look so I told
Mexico and I respect what they did I
said look your laws are very powerful
your laws are very strong we have very
bad laws for a border and we are going
to be doing some things I've been
speaking with general mattis we're going
to be doing things military later until
we can have a wall in proper security
we're going to be guarding our border
with the military that's a big step we
really haven't done that
or certainly not very much before now
think about this all the drug
trafficking human trafficking and of
course the possibility that terrorists
too can cross that border this is a
major national security issue and
there's a reason why Mexico all of a
sudden now appears at the last minute
willing to cooperate with the Trump
administration to stop the caravan now
that's because President Trump is
applying a tremendous amount of pressure
just like he did with little Rocketman
Kim jong-un a president Trump is telling
Mexico if they don't act NAFTA
negotiations will be in jeopardy and he
also threatened to pull foreign aid from
Honduras where many of these migrants
are coming from now it's about time an
American president stood up for our
country's sovereignty and because the
median the left loves to distort
conservative positions on this let me be
clear there's nothing wrong with people
coming to the United States of America
we're just asking it be done legally we
are a constitutional republic we have
laws those laws need to be obeyed you
can't have a country when the illegal
immigrants non citizens can enter as
they please and guess what that's what
the president is now trying to do here
and by the way enough is kind of enough
when it comes to Mexico and people like
their former President Vicente Fox he's
lecturing us about how we deal with
illegal immigration yet under Vicente
Fox Mexico sharply increased their
police their military presence at their
own southern border and they spend
millions of dollars upgrading security
checkpoints as a result from 2002 to
2006 detentions deportations increased
by 74% in Mexico this is ridiculous
beyond hypocritical for Mexico to
constantly be lecturing the United
States regarding immigration laws when
they are far tougher than we've ever
been and for spending sending military
personnel to secure the borders
well liberals and the media are so
outraged the president Trump would dare
to do that here's the thing they're
completely silent of course when
President Obama did that exact thing
back in 2010 back then Obama sent 1200
National Guard troops to the border to
help Border Patrol agents remember in
2014 former Texas Governor Rick Perry he
call
the National Guard to protect the border
because the Obama administration wasn't
doing enough it's not like this is
unprecedented here's another point the
liberal media will never tell you it was
so quick to criticize President Trump
for saying that he wants to use part of
the military's budget to build the
border wall it's a national security
issue now according to a 2009
Congressional Research Service report
the military has already been used to
help construct a border wall by past
presidents including George W Bush and
even Barack Obama those are facts the
media will never tell you any of this
because it doesn't that they're anti
Trump agenda and according to a new
survey 89% of Border Patrol agents say a
wall system in strategic locations is
necessary to secure the border
well that's coming directly from the
people on the ground there every day
risking their lives why not give them
what they're asking for and what
President Trump is calling for is
security and accountability it is that
simple
and for the record this position is
similar to the one that Barack Hussein
Obama once held you may remember him
saying this those who enter our country
illegally and those who employ them
disrespect the rule of law and because
we live in an age where terrorists are
challenging our borders we cannot allow
people to pour into the u.s. undetected
undocumented and unchecked
Wow he sounds like Donald Trump now
Obama only changed his stance when it
became politically expedient and as for
president Trump according to The Wall
Street Journal the Trump administration
will put quotas in place and start
evaluating immigration judges on the
number of cases that they hear in order
to speed up and expedite potential
deportations of illegal immigrants now
remember someone gets caught entering
America illegally they're actually
allowed to stay here until they get to
their court date and about 98% of them
never show up so it's the height of
ignorance and stupidity and that's why
President Trump wants to change it now
other countries for example let's look
at Australia you don't roll out the red
carpet for illegal immigrants like we do
now when Australia catches asylum
seekers trying to enter their country
well they're very compassionate they
give them food they give them water they
give them medical attention if they need
it and then they send the migrants back
to where from where they came
that's beyond pastime America used the
same common-sense measures to secure our
borders all right also brand-new tonight
another major report Sarah Carter who
will join us in a few minutes here's the
headline bombshell secret texts show FBI
DOJ may have rushed anti-trump FISA
warrant and according to Sarah Carter
congressional investigators have now
discovered new text messages between
anti-trump FBI agents lovebirds Peter
stroke and Lisa page that show possible
coordination between the FBI and the DOJ
to get a FISA warrant to spy in the
Trump campaign associate Carter page in
one of the text messages Sarah has
obtained struck is whining and
complaining to Paige that a warrant in
the Russia investigation is being held
up and one of the congressional
investigators is now telling Sarah
tonight quote everything here from the
text complaining about FISA delays to
the exchanges indicating coordination to
the White House visitors log well it
seems to bit match to a disturbing
degree at best it's a strange
coincidence worth investigating now but
of course it's much likely more so you
have the FBI using and unverified
clinton bought and paid for dossier as
part of a FISA application they then
rush to get a FISA warrant approved and
new evidence points to coordination
between the Obama White House the FBI
the DOJ and the CIA Sarah will explain
all of this in a few minutes
now also tonight Robert Muller secures
his first conviction gotta give him a
lot of credit and his witch-hunt a dutch
lawyer was just sentenced to 30 days in
jail 30 whole days and is being ordered
to pay a twenty thousand dollar fine for
lying to the FBI that's it and it had
nothing to do with Russia collusion the
media played this up they thought this
guy was getting 20 years in reality it
looks like a giant waste of your money
now while the media was hyper
focused on this apparent Dutch lawyer
and this travesty they missed the
massive story the proves Robert Muller
is carrying out a witch hunt that is
being aided and abetted by his buddy the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
according to an August memo written by
Rosenstein he actually authorized Muller
to go after Paul Manafort work with the
Ukrainian government which happened way
way before mana fort ever had anything
to do with Donald Trump and the Trump
campaign now in addition to that none of
the charges mana Ford is facing have
anything to do with any of that and of
course that's only half the story
Washington Times reporting that Muller
investigated Paul Manafort on an
allegation from the never corroborated
now known to be lies that Clinton bought
and paid for dossier that came from an
unnamed Russian source and sources it's
pretty shocking but it shouldn't come as
a surprise the special counsel Muller is
corrupt as they come he doesn't seem to
care about truth doesn't care about
facts doesn't care about evidence he
doesn't care about being fair doesn't
care that he's biased look at the team
he's assembled a team of Democratic
donors that donated a Hilary Obama the
DNC and we can't ignore that rod
Rosenstein well he's the guy that
appointed Muller Rosenstein is giving
Muller free rein to do whatever the hell
he wants and whatever happened by the
way to this so-called collusion turned
out to be a witch hunt and Robin
Rosenstein he should be ashamed of
himself
and frankly he's the same guy to sign
the FISA extension against Trump
associate Carter page and then appointed
Muller
does anyone see that as a conflict of
interest and like we have been saying
Rosenstein needs to go and also tonight
a brand-new poll 67% of you the American
people think that a second special
counsel should in fact be named to
investigate all the disturbing FISA
abuses that we have been reporting on in
the media's been ignoring because you
the American people understand the
severity of this because it's a massive
abuse of power and that the DOJ and the
FBI they cannot investigate themselves
because that is a massive conflict of
interest called abuse of power
now while the
Jeff session said he won't be naming a
second Special Counsel he has appointed
Utah prosecutor John Huber since
November we didn't know about it good
for Jeff Sessions to serve in a similar
capacity now while it's not a sec
Special Counsel
it's a massive development and as a
federal prosecutor Hoover will be able
to convene a grand jury gather evidence
issue subpoenas have witnesses testify
and that means he'll be able to properly
investigate these PI's abuses the FBI
putting the fix in on the Clinton email
investigation
click kickbacks to the Clinton
Foundation the corrupt uranium one deal
and of course lying to a FISA judge and
the phony dossier that she paid for a
major development and it's just getting
started another quick point tonight Jill
mccabe she is the wife of the fired FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe well she
has an op-ed in the Washington Post
where she's claiming to be setting the
record straight
now predictably Jill McCabe excuses the
fact that her husband was fired for
lying under oath multiple times about a
number of issues and instead she's
blaming President Trump but the dog
bites of the beast things if you're
feeling sad and if you have a headache
and a hangover its Donald Trump's fault
now Jill mccabe seems to be downplaying
the fact she got over $700,000 in
campaign money from t Clinton allied BFF
Terry McAuliffe and the Virginia
Democratic Party when she had a failed
state Senate run now state Senate
candidates in Virginia they never get
that kind of money
so the McCabe's they can whine all they
want in public about what happened but
facts are facts
you can't change that all right finally
tonight I have a special message for the
abusively biased media that once again
is trying to smear me so yesterday on my
radio show I was making a point about
robert muller dividing this country at a
level we have not seen in forever which
undoubtedly
is doing and has been doing and i made
reference to it's like a civil war in
this country because of his abusively
bias team corrupt democrats people that
see truth we're sick and tired of it and
it's dividing those that hate Trump
those that like Donald Trump well
the person like Andrew Weissman he
appointed now what the media didn't
report to you well I was talking about a
really deep divide that the arrogant
Mulder's creating and that Americans are
more divided than ever and I was
actually talking about family members a
civil war and they're gonna sit at
dinner and they're gonna have food
fights and they're gonna throw mashed
potatoes and broccoli at each other at
the dinner table I wasn't talking about
a real civil war and I was very clear
now the sent the media into a frenzy but
they quickly ignored everything I said
and they raced to take me out of context
like they always do
claiming Oh Hannity wants a civil war in
America no I'm saying we're more divided
than ever and as you know from watching
this show this is what the media does
all the time but I'm not gonna sit back
and take their crap we're gonna call out
the corrupt media in this country for
example the media lost it over me saying
the words civil war okay we went to the
archives they have said it many more
times than I have and we've got the
proof he is clearly trying to ignite a
civil war in this country we are in the
midst of a cold civil war in this
country a political and cultural civil
war today we're watching a civil war
between mostly southern senators loyal
to the man from Alabama and the only
civil war I see is on Twitter and that
doesn't even really matter governor
you've called this an economic civil war
and I know that's what you're touching
on in a way I understand it because
we're fighting the last battle of the
Civil War Oh nobody cared about them
saying it so the media can't stand the
fact and this is the truth night after
night on this program well we are
proving them to be complete total liars
and frauds abusively biased on
everything involving donald trump and
sadly they have missed the biggest story
of their lifetimes while they've been
obsessing over a trump russia collusion
conspiracy theory where there's no
evidence and now that the liberal media
has been exposed they're lashing out of
people like me we've been right
it's no wonder there's a new poll from
Monmouth University showing that 77% of
you the American people believe
the traditional media in this country
reports fake news because they do and at
this point it's pretty much to be
expected but we can promise you we're
always going to fight back against their
extreme bias and their lying